from manchester united's treble-winning
season to liverpool's miracle of
istanbul
european club competition has provided
british football with some of its most
memorable moments
but those two clubs alongside chelsea
manchester city
arsenal tottenham and six more of
europe's biggest and richest teams
are staging a breakaway
under their plans leicester city's
remarkable title winners of 2015 2015-16
would be excluded the threat of
relegation would be removed for the
founding members of the league
europe's existing premier club
competition the champions league
would be decimated i'm disgusted
absolutely disgusted i'm disgusted with
manchester united and liverpool most i
mean liverpool they pretend
you'll never walk alone the people's
club the fans club
manchester united 100 years born out of
workers
around here and they're breaking away
into a league without competition
that they can't be relegated from it's
an absolute disgrace and
honestly we have to wrestle back the
power in this country
from the clubs at the top of this league
the plans would append
the economic and organisational
structures which have held european
football in place for a century
the prime minister tweeted plans for
european super league
would be very damaging for football and
we support authorities in taking action
they would strike at the heart of the
domestic game and will concern fans
across the country
real madrid president florentino perez
has long schemed for a breakaway league
which gives elite clubs
more power under the proposal he would
be its president
beneath him would be a trio of american
billionaires
liverpool owner john w henry arsenal
owner stan cronky
and manchester united owner joel glazer
football associations across europe
including the english fa
condemned the plans the premier league
pledged to block any breakaway
they say fans of any club in england and
across europe
can currently dream that their team may
climb to the top and play against the
best
we believe that the concept of a
european super league would destroy this
dream
clubs like leeds united would
effectively be frozen out of european
club competition
should these plans become a reality but
it's not just
their fans who are incensed it's fans of
all clubs
who feel like their wishes and the rich
history of the game in this country
has been disregarded by greedy
billionaire owners
i'm reading sort of things like
[Music]
banned from other domestic leagues
kicked out of the premier league
international players not allowed to
play for their countries so
i've got a question is it worth it i
just like the champions league and stuff
is is so
i think they should just leave some
argue the proposed breakaway
is just a natural continuation of the
monetization of the game
businesses have have involved themselves
in football much more frequently and
we've seen the increase of the
of course of the size of the premier
league of european competition
with that we've seen bigger commercial
deals some sponsorship endorsements
players of course getting paid so much
more money and that naturally makes it a
more attractive competition to
uh to invest in and i think really that
is a natural
continuation if you like of where
competition is going
that's not to say it's the best
direction of travel for the competition
itself
in many minds football long ago sold its
soul
but some fans will undoubtedly be
repelled by yet another example
of the game's obsession of money and
power at the expense of fair play
martha kellner sky news leads